Trying
to reassure each other and the world.
America's top diplomat and China's leader
were sitting down
for talks earlier today, potentially
a crucial step towards
mending these US-China relations.
The two
global powers
have been at odds,
and that's,
to put it
mildly, over a host of issues
that have sent relations,
frankly, plunging to a new low
Anthony Blinken,
the first US secretary of state
to visit Beijing in five years.
Have a listen.
Here in Beijing,
I had an important conversation
with President Xi Jinping,
and I had candid,
substantive and constructive discussions
with my counterparts
director Wang Yi
and State Councilor Chen Gong.
I appreciate the hospitality
extended by our hosts
in every meeting
I stress that direct engagement
and sustained communication
at senior levels
is the best way
to responsibly manage our differences
and ensure
that competition
does not veer into conflict.
And I heard the same
from my Chinese counterparts.
We both agree on the need
to stabilize our relationship
Well, for
his part, President
Xi says there are reasons to be hopeful.
Have a listen.
To financial planning.
The Chinese side has made
our position clear,
and the two sides
have agreed to follow
through the common understandings.
President Biden
and I had reached in Bali.
The two sides have also made progress
and reached agreement
on some specific issues.
This is very good
Well, key points of contention
between the two global
superpowers of Taiwan, spying
and the war in Ukraine.
And don't
forget us restrictions
on the sale of semiconductor chips.
CNN's U.S.
security correspondent
Kelly Atwood has been
reporting from Beijing.
And here's
what she
told my colleagues a little bit earlier.
One of the things that the
secretary of state
set out here in Beijing to accomplish
was reestablish pushing,
setting up
military to military channels
of communication,
essentially lines of communication
that could be used
in the case of a crisis
between the two countries.
That's given
the fact that there have been
two recent
military incidents
between the US and China
just in recent weeks
in the South China
Sea in the air and by
and by the sea as well.
But that is not an area
where he is headed back to Washington
with a victory.
He said that the Chinese didn't agree
to set up those channels.
Listen to what he told me earlier
today at the press conference.
This is also something
that I raised repeatedly
during this trip.
I think
it's absolutely vital
that we have these kind of communications
military to military.
That imperative, I think, was only
underscored by recent incidents
that we saw in the air and on the seas.
And
at this moment,
China has not agreed to move
forward with that.
I think that's an issue
that we have to keep working on.
It is very important that we restore
those channels
Now, we also know
one of the issues
that you mentioned out of the gates
there was Taiwan.
One of the readouts
from a meeting
that the secretary had here made clear
that Chinese officials
made demands when it comes to Taiwan.
They said
that is the area
that presents the most pronounced risk
to us. China relations.
The secretary of state said
at the press conference
that he made clear
that the US has concerns about China's
provocative actions
when it comes to Taiwan.
And the United States doesn't right now
support Taiwan's independence,
but they don't support either
side taking unilateral actions
that could upend the status
quo currently.
Now, there was progress forward movement
on another topic,
and that's an issue of synthetic opioids,
which of course is a major killer
of Americans back home
setting all the precursor chemicals
or fentanyl largely come from China.
Secretary of State said
that the two sides agreed to stand up
a working level
meeting on this,
a group that can actually address
this issue to stem
that flow of those chemicals
into the United States and on Ukraine.
They also addressed the war in Ukraine.
The secretary said
that Chinese officials once again said
that they are not going to be sending
lethal aid
to Russia to be used in that war,
but they're still watching
Chinese companies incredibly closely
Well, that was CNN's
Connie Atwood reporting from Beijing.
I want to bring in my colleague
and current live from Hong Kong.
And I think what we are hearing
out of
Beijing today is absolutely fascinating.
Just pick apart
what we know at this point and why
it is potentially so significant.
Well, certainly on the issue
of of trade, I mean, these
these are two countries Becky, that,
you know,
the largest economies in the world,
the top two trading partners,
almost $700 billion worth of trade goes
between the United States and China.
And we know that China,
you know,
it needs the United States, its postcode
recovery has not been as strong as it had
hoped.
We know that U.S.
unemployment is is soaring there.
The property market is
is incredibly sluggish.
And China needs its US export
market to flourish.
The US makes up 16% of Chinese exports.
So that is why this is so important.
It is hoped that that from this
visit is a two day visit,
which we didn't know
if Blinken was going to meet with XI.
You know, that
came at the very last minute,
obviously off the back of
10 hours worth of
of accumulative meetings
with the Foreign Ministry
and then China's top diplomat today.
But but, you know, because of that,
Blinken met with XI.
Now, Becky, a short time ago,
we heard from the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs.
They held a briefing
with reporters in Beijing after
Blinken departed for London.
It was Yang Tao.
He's the director
general of the ministry's
North American Ocean
and Oceanian Affairs Department.
And he said
that this visit by Blinken marks
a new beginning in bilateral relations,
which obviously is is very conciliatory.
It's very hopeful.
It's very positive language
coming out of Beijing.
He did, however, say, Becky,
that he rejects
Washington's strategy
of derisking from China.
And that is something that we heard
from Anthony Blinken.
He went on to say that
this us us simply repackaging,
decoupling, as de-risking from China.
The policy is turning away from stability
and opportunity.
It won't solve US problems.
It will cause more problems.
Globally.
Now, obviously, Becky, the hope is that,
you know,
communication lines
have been reestablished.
That was always the aim.
And that from this
the treasury secretary
from the United States, the commerce
secretary from the United States,
will now come to visit
Beijing in the coming weeks because
let's just
be quite
clear about the definition of de-risking.
Thank you all,
because I think it's important here.
And you you will hear
a lot of countries
talking about de-risking at the moment.
What it means is the
and he is a strict
definition of this phenomenon
of financial institutions,
country terminating
or restricting business
relationships with clients
or categories of clients
to avoid rather than manage risk.
It it
tends to be used
within the context
of financial institutions.
And that's where you would hear it.
If you're
across your business news,
you'd have heard the term
derisking in the past.
It's so interesting to see
global leaders using the term we heard
it used at G7 of late.
We've heard
it use once again
by the Americans here in Beijing.
It is a term that you should become
more familiar with.